JJ BEHRENS: Welcome to Dartisms
13, a birthday special.
This is the M1 release
of Dart.
Happy birthday, Seth.
How do you feel?
SETH LADD: Happy birthday, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: This is a big day.
I'm super excited about this.
SETH LADD: I have to say, our
early adopters in our
community really made
this happen.
JJ BEHRENS: This is true.
SETH LADD: We've been working
really hard on
the engineering team.
But we've seen a ton
of libraries.
And part of the things we'll
talk about is how the
community has helped us
get to this point.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, like one bug
at a time, thousands of them.
SETH LADD: Yes.
I think somebody did the math.
It's something like 30 commits
a day averaged out.
JJ BEHRENS: 30 commits a day.
SETH LADD: Our team
has been cranking.
JJ BEHRENS: Definitely, it
moves really quickly.
So I'm JJ Behrens.
This is Seth Ladd.
And later we're going to
have Gilad Bracha.
And we're going to just spend
today celebrating the MI
release of Dart.
Did you bring champagne?
SETH LADD: I didn't.
We're going to do something
bigger for 1.0.
I think one of the main messages
with M1 is this is
our first release since
our public launch
about a year ago.
And this one puts us on
that train for 1.0.
So you'll see more milestones
from here.
But now we're in
a groove here.
And we're really comfortable
with where the project is now
to get us to a later
1.0 stage.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, I was actually
hoping you'd bring
the champagne, because I've been
watching the Giants as
they make their way to
the World Series.
Did you know those guys get to
go through the whole champagne
celebration like four times?
SETH LADD: I just want to dump
Gatorade on Gilad for 1.0.
JJ BEHRENS: That'd be fun.
I'd watch that.
So let's start with
a little bit of
background material first.
And then we'll go into
some M1 features.
And then we'll grill Gilad
really badly with all the M1
intrinsics and stuff
like that.
So what is Dart?
It's about productivity.
It's about more powerful
tools.
Tools to understand more about
your code and can do
more with your code.
And it's about more
structured code.
So that we don't have 10 billion
different libraries
that each have their idea
of what a class is.
SETH LADD: I like to
look at Dart like a
scalable language as well.
Where you can start with a small
set of files, maybe just
one file, top level functions.
You don't even need classes
in the beginning.
And this is a very web
developer thing.
You want to try out an idea.
And then you want to integrate
quickly and scale up or grow
to many, many files, hundreds of
thousands of lines of code.
And that's where that structure
really pays off.
So you integrate the classes,
the implicit interfaces, the
optional static types.
And now you've got maybe 100
developers using all the HTML5
features out there.
And so I love to see that from
small to big story with Dart.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I keep meaning
to do a blog post
where I always say that
languages don't scale
architectures scale.
But that's scalability in terms
of number of servers.
But if you talk about number
of programmers I think Dart
really is--
SETH LADD: Or lines of code.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah,
lines of code.
Then Dart really is aimed to be
a more scalable language.
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
JJ BEHRENS: So the next thing
is it's about performance.
With Dart snapshots, Dart apps
can start up 10 times faster.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
In fact, I think we have
a nice slide here.
Let's tell them what snapshots
are actually.
This is a Dart VM
only feature.
But what it does is it
serializes the token stream
that the parser will create
when it loads in all the
source code.
So of course you can always
start from the source code
which is typical
for a web app.
But of course, the parser has
to do a bunch of steps to
verify that's correct.
But then with a snapshot, you
can snapshot that state before
it starts executing
the program.
And then the next time you start
up, it's about 10 times
faster with our early stats from
Dart to JS which is our
Dart to JavaScript compiler.
That's a significant increase
when you think of things like
mobile devices where the web,
and just usage in general,
computing is just so much
more important.
Those devices typically under
powered compared to these
guys, so anything you can do
with start up speeds is
really, really helpful to get
that app to start right up.
JJ BEHRENS: The way I like to
explain this is if you go to
Gmail, as much as those guys
work on performance and as
crazy as they are about
performance, it still takes a
couple seconds to load up.
Imagine going to Gmail
in a new tab and it
loads up in .2 seconds.
SETH LADD: Or 10 times faster.
That works for me.
JJ BEHRENS: That would
just be amazing.
And also, this is big news.
The Dart VM is actually out
performing the V8 VM.
We like to talk soft a
little bit at Google.
So we don't go shouting things
from mountaintops.
But V8 is the fastest--
SETH LADD: I don't if it's the
fastest but one of fastest.
JJ BEHRENS: According to several
benchmarks, I checked
it by third parties.
It is the fastest browser
according to Tom's Hardware
and so forth.
SETH LADD: Well, OK.
But I know that a couple
benchmarks that we track
internally with the Dart VM it
is now outperforming a couple
benchmarks in V8.
Which is great.
V8s had many, many years and
Dart has had about a year.
And so it's really cool to
see that competition.
I'm sure V8 is going to leap
frog, and we'll do this a lot,
and that's great.
Everybody wins in
that scenario.
JJ BEHRENS: But I think that
there's something to be said
for the fact that Dart is
aimed at performance.
The language itself
is designed for
performance in mind.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So I'm sure you want
to give the disclaimer.
SETH LADD: Well, I think
we alluded to this.
We're not faster in every
benchmark, but certainly part
of the impetus for the whole
project is boost in
performance of both the start
up, which we showed, then also
raw computation performance.
And the language was originally
kicked off by the
V8 engineers so they know what
it takes in language design to
get a faster VM.
And I think we're already
starting to see some of this
pay off which is great.
JJ BEHRENS: And also, Dart
is about doing more.
It's not just a language.
There are a lot of languages,
and very nice looking
languages, that compile
the JavaScript.
But Dart's more than
just a language.
It's also a set of libraries.
It's a new VM.
So I think that's
super exciting.
We have the Dart Editor that
has an amazing knowledge of
your Dart code.
There's Dartium, so
that's the Dart VM
integrated into Chromium.
And then we have the dart2js
so that we can compile the
JavaScript to support all
those other browsers.
SETH LADD: I think that's one of
the most important, if not
most important, aspects of the
project is that all this great
work that we're doing can get
compiled down to modern
JavaScript, ECMAScript 5, and
run across mobile desktop and
mobile and desktop browsers.
And that's fantastic.
So you can write Dart code
today and it's not just a
Chrome thing.
It's a modern web thing.
JJ BEHRENS: So demo time.
You want to take it over Seth?
SETH LADD: Sure, let me do
a couple demos here.
In fact, I think this is a good
time to introduce our
special guest.
We're going to talk about some
of the new M1 features.
JJ BEHRENS: Gilad Bracha is
here to talk with us.
Wave hello, Gilad.
GILAD BRACHA: Hey, hello.
JJ BEHRENS: So he's going to set
us straight in case we get
anything wrong.
GILAD BRACHA: Oh, I could
never set you straight.
SETH LADD: Well, we should say
that part of the M1 release is
a lot of changes to
the language.
And a lot of this is driven by
feedback, and we've been
writing a lot of Dart
code ourselves.
And so, I know Gilad you've run
through a lot of different
spec revisions since M1.
I'd like to dive into one of the
ones that comes from small
talk first.
Which I think is maybe slightly
unfamiliar to some of
our developers out there.
But method cascades, can
you talk a little bit?
Where did that come from
and what do you
hope to do with them?
GILAD BRACHA: So method
cascades, historically, they
come from small talk.
It's basically a situation where
you want to send the
same receiver, the same target
object, is when you get a
series of messages.
And rather than repeat that
receiver over and over again
declaring a local variable,
probably to store whatever
receiver it was and then doing
that, you have a syntactic
sugar for that.
And that works nicely in
circumstances in UI, in things
that are sort of the jQuery
style of things.
And so it seemed to
apply to the web.
It's a little bit different than
the original, but people
seem to like it.
Like any other construct, it
requires a bit of taste and
judgment so you don't abuse
it and get into trouble.
But if you format it nicely it
works well, and gives people a
nice way of saving
a few keystrokes.
And explaining what
they're doing.
SETH LADD: I have
a demo of this.
Maybe we can go to the laptop
screen, and hopefully the font
is big enough.
I pulled up two examples that
did the same thing.
The top is the method
cascade syntax.
This as big as I can get it.
Sorry.
But anyway, so Gilad
mentioned saving a
couple of key strokes.
The bottom example you see I
repeat button dot value button
dot classes button dot text.
It seems a little repetitive
to me.
And Gilad, you mentioned
the J Query.
There's a slight difference
there though.
That's a chaining type
of API, right?
And so cascades is slightly
different than chaining?
GILAD BRACHA: Well it is but you
can use it for some of the
same things, right?
The real fundamental thing is it
can help you design an API
that will work well with that.
And so it actually can change
how you structure your library
once you know it's there.
JJ BEHRENS: That's one thing
that I like about this feature
is we have this thing that we
constantly do, but with just a
little bit a syntactic
sugar it makes the
code read a lot nicer.
SETH LADD: And I figured out
how to make this bigger so
hurray on me.
OK, good.
This is one of the features
I'm really excited about.
I've already used it when I
program a lot of HTML APIs.
And a lot of that's just set the
ID, set the classes, set
the button handlers,
et cetera.
I don't know.
I like it.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, don't
repeat yourself.
You know?
SETH LADD: That's right.
What are the other
ones we have?
JJ BEHRENS: This dot constructor
arguments.
SETH LADD: OK, cool.
This one's been in before M1.
This is one of my
favorite things.
And as a Java developer, and I
think in other languages too,
always repeating in the
constructor this
dot x equals x.
This dot y equals y.
Very common pattern, so
what do we do in Dart?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, just in case
you haven't seen one of our
other talks where
we covered this.
Rather than receiving a
parameter called Name and
saying this dot name equals
name, you could just receive
this dot name and it does
it automatically.
If you look at this code sample,
we have a constructor
called Person and the
body is empty.
It's just a semi colon.
And we're receiving
two parameters.
This dot name and this
dot position.
And it automatically saves them
into name and position.
SETH LADD: In fact, I think what
it does is it actually
puts it in the initializer
list.
Is that correct?
It doesn't actually do it in
the constructive body?
JJ BEHRENS: No, I think it's--
GILAD BRACHA: Yeah, but you
really don't care is the
bottom line.
It's really at the beginning
of the initialize list.
It'll happen before
anything else that
you might have written.
JJ BEHRENS: Now there's some
other languages that have a
feature similar to this.
Where they declare the name
instance member inside the
constructor.
And you might wonder why we
didn't do that, why we have
these things separate.
And that's because we support
multiple constructors.
So we could have one normal
constructor and then the named
constructor.
And so it makes sense.
SETH LADD: Here's an
example of that.
A lot of times you might build
up objects from JSON or some
binary sterilization format.
And thanks to name constructors,
you can actually
create person dot from
JSON for instance.
I could say something like
JSON string here.
Which I love, because now it
tells me right there when I'm
using that instructor what
its intention is.
JJ BEHRENS: So I guess we
just did a two-fer.
Because you just showed
us named constructors.
SETH LADD: Awesome.
JJ BEHRENS: I don't know of many
other languages that did
named constructors.
Can you think of any?
GILAD BRACHA: No, the thing
about Dart constructors that's
really interesting, and named
constructors is part of that,
is that they retain the
familiarity of constructors
without the real problem
that constructors have
traditionally.
Which is that you're stuck
creating an instance of this
particular class, creating a
new instance, you can't use
constructors to get something
out of a cache.
You can't use them if you, for
some reason, need to produce
something else that obeys
the same interface.
Right?
It's all about objects
that behave the same.
You can't do all that stuff.
SETH LADD: These are the
factory constructors.
GILAD BRACHA: So Dart
constructors are really
interesting, because they really
give you the advantages
that people try to get
with all kinds of
static factory patterns.
But you don't have to go through
the boiler plate and
you don't have to learn
something radically different.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
I definitely think this is yet
another case where, if you're
coming from a Java or C+
background, there are certain
pain points in the language.
And you know what they
are, and so you know
all the work arounds.
If just fix it in the language
with a little bit a syntactic
niceness, you can not
have to suffer from
those things anymore.
SETH LADD: So let's talk about
another feature that's
been in before M1.
And so this is the last one
we'll show that's been there
before, but I really,
really like.
And it's lexical scope
or lexical closures.
So we have a demo up here.
And this is something
Dart does I think
really, really well.
Actually, we're seeing a couple
things here right?
We're seeing the one line
in one functions and
also lexical code.
Can you walk us through
this code?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, sure, so we
have a function called main.
And we have a local variable
called numPresses.
And we're going to query to
find increment button.
And if you know jQuery
this looks familiar.
And then we have On Click Add.
And then the thing inside
parentheses is a call back.
It receives an event object
and the function just does
numPresses plus, plus.
Now that's a nested function,
but it has access to
numPresses that's in
the outer scope.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: Now in the next
slide we have query for
show-num-presses.
And so this is a different
button.
And we do On Click Add
for that button.
And here we used a different
syntax for a function.
This time we're using
curly braces instead
of the arrow syntax.
And we do window dot alert,
number of presses with
numPresses.
So this is an example of the
string interpolation.
But once again, we are getting
access to numPresses which is
from the outer function.
And so, in a certain sense,
closures and classes there's a
little bit of overlap.
We have some shared state.
And we have two different
methods, basically, that
operate on that shared state.
And yet it's still small
and elegant.
SETH LADD: I would say maybe
not shared state.
That makes me think
of threads.
It's not the scoping right?
I could see it lexically, that
is the structure of the
program defines what functions
get to which variables.
Which I love.
You can just take a look
at it and tell
what's going to happen.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, it's just
very light overhead.
if.
You tried to this in say
JavaScript, where you have
this nested function and
you're using this,
this will get lost.
It won't refer to the
actual object.
It'll refer to the
window object.
And if you've ever had that bug
it's extremely painful.
SETH LADD: So let's show a
couple Editor features now
that you've shown some code.
OK, cool.
Which one do we want to show?
We talked about performance,
but we also talked about
productivity.
And the Editor really helps
us with that productivity.
So I'll show a couple
things here.
Here's just some code
I'm opening up.
But as your code base grows,
and scales up to a large
number of developers, you're
going to need to start
updating the code, cleaning
it up, based
on what you've learned.
And the last thing you want to
do is globally search and
replace and then hope all your
name's are unique et cetera.
You want your tools to handle
these cleanups and maintenance
tasks for you.
This is where refactoring
comes in.
JJ BEHRENS: This rename you're
about to show is really
important, because as an old
school JavaScript programmer I
come from the days before
minimizers.
And so I named all my variables
a, aa, ab, ac and
it's a bad habit.
SETH LADD: Not everyone
has your super skills.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, you know
a photographic memory.
SETH LADD: Let's run
this rename.
In fact, I'm going to
do one thing here.
So I want to rename this
connections variable here.
But let's go down in here and
let's, just to prove the point
here, I'm going to create
another connections object
down in a totally different
scope down in main.
And I want to show how this is
not just a glorified search
and replace right?
This actually understands the
structure of the code.
So if I rename--
let's say that's too long or
I want to be more specific.
So web socket connection, so
notice how it's actually
changing the rest of the
variable names on the fly.
But if I scroll down, right,
the other connections for a
totally different object
are left unchanged.
And that's the power of the
Editor being able to
statically analyze the program,
understand the
structure, and give you these
refactoring tools.
Which I love.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm trying to do it
as a VIN plug-in but that's
actually pretty hard.
SETH LADD: It is hard.
So let's say also as you scale
up programs, you're going to
grow the number of developers
on your team.
And you're going to grow the
size of the program.
You can't fit it all
in your head.
And of course, your new
guy comes on he can't
just absorb the code.
He's going to be working with
new APIs he's unfamiliar with.
So can the tools help
you with that?
Of course, we have a feature
called Code Completion.
So let's see if I can
zoom in here.
JJ BEHRENS: And you hit Control,
Space, and you
automatically popped up with
all the available methods.
And if you don't happen to
have the full API for
everything in Dart memorized
it's actually
really, really helpful.
SETH LADD: Yeah, especially
integrating with a new team or
using a third party library.
These tools should be able to
walk you through that process.
I love that.
JJ BEHRENS: That's definitely
for coding in the large.
Because you know, the bigger the
code base gets the harder
it is to have all those things
in your mental cache space.
SETH LADD: Yes, so I love the
fact that I'm more productive
with these kind of tools.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
SETH LADD: OK, so the last
demo with the Editor for
productivity is using the Editor
to launch into Dartium,
which is Chromium with the VM,
and then also compiling to
JavaScript.
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
SETH LADD: And debugging
this code.
So debugging, obviously,
very important.
You don't want to run print
statements everywhere.
So let's show an example
of that.
I believe if I launch this
project here while in Dartium.
JJ BEHRENS: So here you are
running with Dart code
natively using the Dart
VM running in
a version of Chromium.
SETH LADD: It's running fine.
So let's go back over
to-- whoa, hello--
let's load up one of these.
And let's set a breakpoint.
OK, so what happened
right here?
So I'm going to zoom
in over here.
The debugger in the Editor
launched immediately the
instance I set the
break point.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
just amazing.
You set the break point
and you didn't
even restart the app.
SETH LADD: Right, so let's
go over to the app.
And it's frozen.
So the Editor is talking
to Dartium.
I love this.
So then you can step
through the code.
You can run it again.
JJ BEHRENS: There's a stack
with local variables.
SETH LADD: So this is that
integrated debugging.
So you might be like, OK that's
great obviously for 95%
of your development.
But then you have to go test
in other browsers right?
That last 5%.
So let's show you how
you might do that.
Well, I'm going to run
as JavaScript here.
And the Editor is going to run
Dart to JS which is itself
written in Dart which
is very cool.
JJ BEHRENS: I got no respect for
non self hosted languages.
SETH LADD: So what
is it doing here?
So it launches into Chromium.
So this is regular Chromium.
It doesn't know a thing
about Dart.
And then you're saying, well of
course how do I debug this?
Isn't compiled code really
complicated and everything?
So let's load up the dev tools
here, and oh this is
interesting.
So I'm going to zoom
in, whoa--
JJ BEHRENS: There you go.
SETH LADD: --and we have here,
sorry everyone, the Dev tools,
the Source tab, actually
showing me Dart code.
Now how is this possible?
Because Chrome doesn't
know anything about
Dart it just has V8.
Well, we have this really cool
feature called Source Maps
which when you compile the
JavaScript it also generates
this mapping file between the
Dart source code and the
compiled output JavaScript.
And it shows all that to
Chrome's dev tools, which then
goes through this
mapping file.
And when you open up and do
debug, here's an actual break
point of Dart code.
JJ BEHRENS: That is
just amazing.
SETH LADD: Mapped into the
JavaScript code all behind the
scenes for you.
And of course, the
app is stopped.
So now you can debug compiled
JavaScript via Dart in
Chrome's developer tools.
JJ BEHRENS: I have to say, this
is my favorite feature
from dev tools for like
the entire year.
SETH LADD: This is fantastic.
Source maps is not just
a Dart thing.
I believe other languages
compile source maps.
JJ BEHRENS: You want to
step over some code?
SETH LADD: Sure, let's
show you that.
Same kind of deal, right?
You can set the breakpoints.
You can step over and--
JJ BEHRENS: The one
to the right.
SETH LADD: --let's see
if that works.
Yep.
JJ BEHRENS: We're stepping.
That's just amazing.
SETH LADD: Very, very
cool stuff.
JJ BEHRENS: And that's just
in normal Chrome.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
OK, awesome.
So that's the demo portion.
Let's talk about M1.
JJ BEHRENS: M1.
SETH LADD: What is M1?
JJ BEHRENS: I still think we
should have worn suits to
celebrate this.
SETH LADD: 1.0.
What is M1?
JJ BEHRENS: So M1 is our first
release milestone.
It's our signal to developers
that things are stabilizing.
That now is a good
time to start
building your app in Dart.
That we're going to try really
hard to not make backwards
incompatible changes, but
rather we're going to be
polishing the language, adding
to it, and then working a lot
on performance.
But this is still
a 0.1 release.
I still think we should
call it a 0.9.
SETH LADD: Versions
don't mean much.
But I think the message there
is that it's early
and it's not a 1.0.
But we're starting this release
train and a lot has
stabilized.
JJ BEHRENS: So, tell
me what's new.
SETH LADD: Well, a lot
of language features.
And so I want to dive in.
Let's see, we can actually
load up.
We have a nice article on
dartlang.org about--
let's just load up this guy.
There you go.
Oh, OK, here we go.
Let's fix the link.
There's a nice article on the
dartlang.org site about the
different language
changes for M1.
There's quite a big list.
This is a perfect time to chat
with Gilad I know, because you
helped shuttle a lot of these
changes through based on
feedback or not.
And so I want to start with
which one of these are you
most excited about?
Some of the changes since
our first launch?
GILAD BRACHA: The one that I'm
most excited about is actually
the removal of something.
SETH LADD: Tell us about that.
GILAD BRACHA: Adding features
is easy and it
doesn't always help.
What helps is getting
rid of stuff which
usually you can't do.
And the fact that we've got rid
of interface declarations
has kind of--
which itself relied on the
fact that classes act as
interfaces vis-a-vis
the type system.
And you can implement a class
and you could do that before.
And each of those things were
just based on the fundamental
understanding of what
an object oriented
language should be.
So that's really
the good thing.
It simplifies so much.
SETH LADD: Deleting
stuff, code or in
spec, is always good.
GILAD BRACHA: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So if someone's
out there and he's saying,
well interfaces are good?
What are you talking about you
got rid of interfaces?
What do they use instead
of interfaces?
GILAD BRACHA: Interfaces are
good and interfaces logically
are still there, because the
entire system is based on the
notion of interface.
What matters is what object
interfaces is.
But we don't have interface
declarations.
Because once you have interface
declarations, you
had to decide well am I going to
declare an interface or use
an abstract class or use the
class I already have?
And if I put an interface
what are the trade offs?
Well gee, I can't put static
methods in there.
What about the default values
for the parameters?
There are all kinds of questions
that came up.
And the best solution is to nip
this in the bud and get
rid of all these questions.
JJ BEHRENS: So now they would
just use an abstract class,
and you could say that you
implement the abstract class
or you extend the abstract
class and it's
kind of up to you.
GILAD BRACHA: It depends.
If it's a purely abstract class
than you probably want
to implement it.
If it has functionality that
you want to reuse you
might extend it.
The advantage, of course, of
implementing is that there
might be several.
Right?
If it's really acting as an
interface then you don't want
to get into this business of
conflicting implementations
from multiple inheritants.
But multiple classifications,
in the sense of supporting
multiple interfaces, doesn't
raise any of those questions.
And that's what you'd
end up doing.
The nice thing about these
abstract classes is that they
can still use the factory
constructors we
talked about earlier.
So that you can actually just
refer to this type throughout
your system, and create new
instances and it might, if
it's set up correctly, it may
be able to actually produce
instances of a particular
concrete class.
JJ BEHRENS: Very good.
SETH LADD: Are there any cases
where you've already taken
advantage of this new
functionality in the libraries?
Have you noticed anything?
GILAD BRACHA: We're still in
transition there, right?
So the goal of M1 was to get
past the stage of breaking
language changes.
Breaking library changes, I
think, are still plenty to
come to be honest.
SETH LADD: And in fact, the
Editor has this really great
cleanup feature.
Because you're right, I suspect
a lot of library stuff
is going to happen.
So a lot of people might say
if I write Dart code today
what's going to happen?
Well, this is the advantage
of a language that's more
structured and analyzable.
The cleanup feature, it's really
cool, it will change
from the old syntax to
new syntax for you.
JJ BEHRENS: I love that.
SETH LADD: I feel more
comfortable now with the
upcoming changes.
GILAD BRACHA: So we still are
supporting some of the old
syntax, and that will go
away probably by in 2.
And the Editor will
automatically convert for you.
JJ BEHRENS: Wait a second, did
you leak the fact that there's
going to be an M2 after an M1?
GILAD BRACHA: I did
not leak anything.
I announced.
SETH LADD: Having stated,
it is fact.
There will be an M2.
JJ BEHRENS: There will be.
I wonder if Lars knows?
SETH LADD: That's right.
Well, another big feature--
and it's actually a collection
of features in M1--
was the changes or enhancements
to the libraries.
We added re-export
and a new syntax.
Can you talk about some of the
things that helped us?
GILAD BRACHA: Right so again,
the library design went
through a lot of ups and downs
over the past year, year and a
half, since we started.
Certainly it became clear that
the original functionality
wasn't quite enough.
So partly there were syntactic
complaints which were
understandable.
There was some motivation behind
the old syntax, but it
didn't really wash.
And so the new syntax is
cleaner, less noise.
But the important thing is
functionality, that you have
better control over the name
spaces of libraries.
So the export directive
basically lets you say that
very often you find you have
these libraries that are just
aggregating a bunch of
other libraries.
And they want to provide that
same API to their users
without them necessarily
being aware of all the
sub-components.
So you can re-export the
API of another library.
The other thing you can do is
you can control how much,
because we have these show and
hide commentators, that let
you say that I only want to
export these identifiers from
this library.
So I can say show ABC, and
I'll only get ABC.
Or I can say I want to hide
this one because it might
conflict with something else.
And so I can narrow down these
name spaces and control them.
And that gives you a pretty
powerful way of snapping
things together.
SETH LADD: And this is all about
that scalability right?
I mean you can start without
libraries, even without
classes if you want, and as
you grow you can introduce
libraries and then maybe
compose libraries.
I love it.
It just helps you grow.
GILAD BRACHA: Right, and we
tweaked a few of the rules
about libraries because on one
hand we do want to let people
know about conflicts.
On the other hand, we really
want code to be robust.
Because third parties are
adding stuff to their
libraries, and what if it
suddenly conflicts with yours?
So some of the rules have
changed a bit to make that
hold up better.
So your library takes priority
over stuff that you're
importing, things like that.
So I think we're in
much better shape
there than we were.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So there's a ton of
features here.
SETH LADD: There's almost
too many features.
I don't know.
Anything else you like here?
JJ BEHRENS: I think that a lot
of people, perhaps if they're
at a moderate level of knowing
Dart, they might not know all
of these new M1 features.
So can we look at this
slide real quick?
And we'll zoom in, and why don't
we just run down these
super quickly.
I know that there's a lot.
SETH LADD: Help me pick
out a couple.
But you're right, if you first
or only saw Dart about a year
ago a lot has changed.
JJ BEHRENS: This is one
of those articles
that's a must read.
SETH LADD: Yeah, make sure
of the title here.
So Milestone 1 Language Changes
on dartlang.org.
And it's really nice.
Bob Nystrom has done
a great job here
with examples as well.
So it's not just an enumeration,
but it's also--
there's some justification
in here and examples
of before and after.
JJ BEHRENS: One of the ones I
love is the fact that we now
have some notion of
first class types.
And the reason I love this is
because I like to remember
what Dart stands for according
to the language spec.
It's Dynamic and Reified Types
if I remember right?
GILAD BRACHA: I am not sure
where you got that, but it
makes sense to me.
JJ BEHRENS: I had to ask
another language guy.
I was like, what does
reified mean?
He was like, duh you
should know that.
SETH LADD: I think we need
to update this article.
FYI.
JJ BEHRENS: It's all about
dynamic and reified Types.
GILAD BRACHA: That's news
to me, but I like it.
It's interesting how people come
up with these post facto
interpretations.
JJ BEHRENS: Yes, and that one
was post facto yes absolutely.
SETH LADD: So M1 is more than
just a slew of the language
refinements and changes right?
There's also platform
additions as well.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so a lot
of new Editor features.
Man, the Editor moves
at a furious pace.
Those guys, as soon as I create
a bug it seems like
next week it's fixed.
I don't know how they do it.
SETH LADD: Well some of the
new features you saw
re-factoring, but they
have quick fixes.
Which is somewhere between
code clean up and
re-factoring.
There's actually the explicit
cleanup that helps
you update your code.
The debugging, so lots of good
stuff in the Editor.
JJ BEHRENS: Now I remember
when Dart first came out,
people really took us to task
for generating large
JavaScript output.
And this was something about the
fact that we were trying
to do small talk like
hot code reloading.
But these days, we have much
smaller JavaScript output.
Because we do all kinds
of things like tree
shaking and so forth.
So that in the JavaScript world
you might want to use a
bunch of libraries, but you get
really, really paranoid
about how big is this library.
How much is this going
to cost my page?
But with Dart and with dart2js
we could just tree shake and
you only have to pay for
what you actually use.
SETH LADD: Yeah, and so here's
a dart2js output.
You're right, it was quite
large in the beginning.
We are on the third generation
dart2js compiler.
I just compiled a hello world,
which just says hello world,
in Dart into JavaScript.
And right now it's
2,400 bytes.
So we've made tremendous
improvements there, and I
think the team continues
to reduce the size.
But, yeah, I'm happy
where we are.
JJ BEHRENS: I would say another
thing to point out is
that Dart doesn't
really entirely
disappear at run time.
There's some languages where
they have this approach where
you compile it to JavaScript,
and there is no
notion of the run time.
Whereas, that was not
one of our goals.
We really wanted a run time.
So you could ask a generic,
are you a list of buttons?
SETH LADD: I would think of it
like we need to retain the
semantics of the language.
So it's not like we bring over
the Dart run time with
JavaScript, but you're right
there are differences in terms
of semantics when you call a
method and it doesn't exist or
integers or generics.
We bring those over as
well through dart2js.
JJ BEHRENS: And if you turn on
checked mode, you'll get type
assertions at run time which is
great during development.
You could catch if you're
creating type
mistakes at run time.
SETH LADD: Well, one of the
big asks we had that we're
delivering here with M1 is our
JavaScript interoperability
which is huge.
This allows you to integrate
with JavaScript code like
Google Maps or your own in house
JavaScript code and use
it straight with Dart.
This is all open source.
This is on GitHub as well.
We'll let you guys
check it out.
But yeah, we've got demos of
Google Maps, Twitter API,
couple others actually written
with Dart using those stateful
[INAUDIBLE] and JavaScript
APIs.
JJ BEHRENS: So the one thing I
want to point out about the
JS, Dart, interrupt if
you look at this
closely it's not trivial.
Certain languages they compile
to JavaScript and there's no
disconnect at all between
those two languages.
And so you might wonder, well
why does it seem a little bit
harder in Dart?
And that's because we want
to support the Dart VM.
We want to have things like
faster VM performance.
We want to run way faster.
We want those things
like snapshots.
And getting two different
VMs to work
together is not so easy.
There's some cross VM garbage
collection issues.
And so, yes it is a little
bit harder than some
certain other languages.
Not impossible.
SETH LADD: Well here, so let's
go to the computer screen.
You can see an example
of Google Maps.
And I actually think it's pretty
straightforward. you're
right, it's not like a config
script integration.
But with a couple, I would
almost say wrapping functions,
there's a way to declare what
the scope is of some of these
JavaScript variables.
There's a way to create a Dart
proxy of a JavaScript object.
But that's just the boilerplate
set up.
When you're actually dealing
with the actual business
logic, which is the majority of
the code, this is the part
that I've highlighted
right here.
It's Dart code.
JJ BEHRENS: It's invisible,
behind the scenes, proxies.
It's not difficult, but I just
want to point out with the
Dart VM we're going to get all
these additional benefits.
SETH LADD: We need to work
in a multiple VM world.
JJ BEHRENS: Dart wants to push
the web forward, and so this
is us pushing the web forward.
SETH LADD: One of the other huge
additions to the platform
is our package manager.
All big successful programming
ecosystems, if you will, have
a great package manager.
JJ BEHRENS: That went live,
what, like an hour ago?
SETH LADD: This is part
of the release.
We call it Pub because you
play darts in a pub.
So let's do a demo of that.
So we have the ability to
publish packages on a
centralized hosting pub,
the dartlang.org.
Soon you, as external
developers, will be able to
upload and publish your
own packages.
And today you can use those
packages hosted at Pub.
So I think I have an example
of that here.
This is one of my
favorite demos.
JJ BEHRENS: That's awful.
SETH LADD: OK, so let's
start here.
So on the computer screen
here you've got--
it's a simple app.
But it's referring to three
different packages.
And I'm going to get
these from Pub.
And of course, my Editor here
doesn't know anything about
them, because I haven't
installed them yet.
But thanks to our integration
with Pub into the Editor, I
can just go up to Tools
and run Pub Install.
It helps if I choose
the directory.
Let's do that.
So now it's running out to Pub
and various sources declared
where to get the
packages from.
And it pulls them down and
creates all the necessary
symlinks so that my local
application understands where
these different packages are.
And it's all relative
to the project.
So let's hope this
finishes here.
JJ BEHRENS: Ahh,
the demo gods.
SETH LADD: Uh-oh.
JJ BEHRENS: So we launched
Pub today at, what is it?
Pub.dartlang.org.
So we already have a long list
of packages, but over the
coming quarter we're hoping to
really, really increase that.
So if you have a library that
you could import to Dart put
it on Pub and then everyone
will benefit.
A lot of people--
I talk to a lot of kids and
they're like, oh I want to get
into Google.
And I always ask, well do
you have any open source
contributions?
Now is a really good time.
Import a library, get it up on
GitHub, get it up on Pub, and
become famous.
And it's done for a
profit, I think.
SETH LADD: Well if I can
get the demo back I
will go back to it.
But we've got a lot of good
questions from the community.
So let's go back to Gilad.
I want to start with--
let's set the record
straight, I think.
is Dart out to replace
JavaScript?
JJ BEHRENS: Why do you hate
JavaScript so much?
GILAD BRACHA: Oh, you're not
interested in why I hate or
love anything.
Dart is not out to replace
JavaScript.
This is something that, I guess,
various commentators
jump to that conclusion.
And once that happens, no amount
of denials will help.
I mean not that I personally--
I mean, there's a long list
of programming languages I
personally would eradicate.
But that's not what Google
is trying to do here.
We compiled a JavaScript.
I mean one thing about people at
Google, whatever people may
say of us, I don't think they
often say that we're stupid.
And so the idea of getting rid
of JavaScript is quite
unrealistic.
And we have no interest
in doing that.
We're compiling to JavaScript,
because we see JavaScript as a
substrate that can
enable languages
and multiple languages.
Dart, of course,
but potentially
lots of other languages.
Just like x86 or any other
part of the ecosystem.
The question is, do you want
to work with it directly?
And I don't think so.
SETH LADD: So it just builds on
the existing lingua franca
infrastructure of the web.
JJ BEHRENS: And we have a lot
of people at Google who
really, really love
JavaScript.
Those Angular guys,
man, they love it.
SETH LADD: Good framework.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, it
is good framework.
SETH LADD: So this I'm
really curious about.
So you've seen a bunch of Dart
code get written the past
year, and iterations of spec.
What is some of the best
feedback you've received?
GILAD BRACHA: The best feedback
is feedback that
tells you about a problem.
Right?
So I'm trying to do this with a
library, because I have Dart
HTML and it's too big and I
want to show people only a
part of it.
Generally feedback that tells
you about a problem someone's
trying to solve, as opposed to
feedback that tells you I want
this thing from my favorite
language.
That is prescriptive
solutions.
Because the prescriptive
solutions aren't
very useful to me.
They're not likely to actually
work in a different setting.
If they do they'll bring the
exact same problems that they
had in that setting.
And so you really want to listen
to people tell you
about their problems
not the solutions.
JJ BEHRENS: This is definitely
a good case why languages
designed by committee, with
the exception of Haskell,
don't always work
out so smoothly.
GILAD BRACHA: Umm.
Please go on.
SETH LADD: So what I'm hearing
is we love the feedback that's
more about use cases.
Tell us what you're trying to
do, and what was difficult,
and we'll help come up
with a solution.
GILAD BRACHA: Right.
SETH LADD: Well, M1
is a stabilization
but we're not done.
GILAD BRACHA: Oh, by no means.
SETH LADD: We've got a couple
things coming down the pipe.
Can you give us a little
hint about what
you're thinking about?
GILAD BRACHA: So mix ins is
something we already--
I think we last spoke about it
already at Google I/O and
mentioned that we'd do that.
So that'll be coming at some
point down the pipeline.
I'm very excited about that.
Again, that's something
that helps you
structure things better.
There are very concrete
scenarios.
That's one of the reasons
libraries will be heavily
impacted by that, because you'll
be able to organize
things in a way that'll let
you share code more
effectively and so forth.
Then of course mirrors, it's
not really a language
construct, but it's more a
magical library that lets you
do things with the language.
And so right now we have
introspection in the VM.
But we don't have support for
all this stuff in dart2js.
So we're warning people
about that.
We don't want anyone playing
with it in the VM and then
suddenly realizing that
it's not going to
work for them in dart2js.
And there's a lot more to
mirrors beyond the current
introspection support that
we'd like to do.
Adding and changing code
dynamically, debugging
support, making things
like [INAUDIBLE]
trivial, making fix and continue
debugging trivial.
That sort of thing.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm really looking
forward to that.
GILAD BRACHA: And of course,
this is complicated in the
Dart context because of these
issues of you don't really
download all your code.
Or your code gets mangled,
minified, whatever.
And having mechanisms
to control that.
So we don't want a situation
where just because you used
mirrors suddenly all bets
are off and suddenly
your download explodes.
Because we want to give you
a relatively fine grained
mechanism using metadata, which
is another new feature
that has just come in, to
specify well I'm going to need
this stuff reflectively.
Even though it isn't actually
being used right now
so please keep it.
Preserve that information
for me.
Things like that.
SETH LADD: I love to see the
language continue to evolve.
This is great.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
SETH LADD: All right, we're
going to try this
demo one more time.
Here we go, everyone
cross your fingers.
So we're back at the computer
screen here.
And I restarted the Editor.
The errors still exist here
in the simple app
about missing packages.
But let's go ahead and see
if we can run Pub again.
OK, it wasn't meant to be.
That's all right.
JJ BEHRENS: It wasn't
meant to be.
SETH LADD: That's OK.
It worked for me yesterday.
That's a typical response
from programmers, right?
Or it worked on my machine.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I'm
so sorry about that.
It's funny.
It always works.
Pub is not one of those
things that
causes me a lot of problems.
SETH LADD: OK, so it looked
like it worked.
It just, no, nevermind.
We'll come back.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, sorry
about that.
SETH LADD: But we're
only M1 right?
So it's OK we're allowed
one bug.
JJ BEHRENS: One bug.
Until M2 right?
GILAD BRACHA: Then we'll
have two bugs.
Yeah, actually probably
a lot more.
That's another thing, when we
say that the language is
stable you have to take that
with a grain of salt in the
sense that we have no intention
of making any more
breaking changes unless we've
really screwed up.
And the other thing is, from
the end developer's
perspective, the fact that the
spec says well this is the way
it is and we don't intend
to change that.
Obviously there are going to be
bugs, so people will still
have to adjust to things working
differently than the
way they work right now.
And library changes are just as
important, if not more so.
And there will be additions, but
those additions we don't
see them impacting what's
already there.
It'll be a way of wave
breaking them.
So the main message is we're
past the radical language
reshuffling phase.
JJ BEHRENS: I think that if
people want to stay current on
these things they should
just follow the blog.
I mean, every time we're
discussing upcoming things
it's on the blog.
SETH LADD: Right.
Another big change coming
down is web components.
JJ BEHRENS: Web components.
SETH LADD: Web components are
a future spec really made
available today thanks to
our compilation step.
So it's an encapsulation model
around the structure, and the
behavior, and the style of
elements that you would
typically just lay
out on your page.
Thanks to web components you can
encapsulate them up into
new elements and compose
your page out
of more true elements.
And the Dart team has been
hard at work, again open
source on GitHub, to make
the web component
model a reality today.
And we've already got some
demo apps like to do MVC.
So I expect to see
more of those.
And along with the library
updates, and language
evolution stuff, but also a lot
more with web components.
So stay tuned for that.
JJ BEHRENS: Web components
are big.
SETH LADD: So you alluded
to the news and
update service we have.
So this is a lot of stuff we
just presented here, and the
train is going to
keep on rolling.
What are some good ways that
people can get involved and or
follow along with Dart?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, you could
start by going to
dartlang.org.
You could download the Editor.
There's a mailing list that
moves crazy fast.
I can't read as fast
as it moves.
But if you have questions about
specific things you're
stuck on in your Dart code,
I think you should post
questions to Stack Overflow.
And remember, if you ask a
question and then Seth or me
answers it you've
got to +1 it.
Because my salary is directly
connected to the little green
check marks.
SETH LADD: We're now an
officially sponsored tag on
Stack Overflow for Dart which
I'm really happy with.
A lot of good community
involvement there.
Great.
And then, dartbug.com.
JJ BEHRENS: Dartbug.com, so my
favorite thing is I come up
with some random crazy feature
because I wake up in a cold
sweat in the middle
of the night.
The first thing I do is I whip
out my Android phone and I go
to dartbug.com/new and I
create a new feature.
And then the next day
Gilad says, JJ
stop doing that maybe.
SETH LADD: But it is great.
Your bugs and feedback
we love.
It's really helped evolve the
language and libraries, the
platform, to where
it is today.
And I'm hoping to see the
community continue to grow.
So thanks for supporting
Dart up to M1.
We look forward to hosting
more packages on Pub and
seeing more cool Dart
libraries and
apps out there soon.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
Gilad, thanks for joining us.
GILAD BRACHA: Thank you.
SETH LADD: Thank you
very much Gilad.
JJ BEHRENS: Thank you
all for watching
this episode of Dartisms.
SETH LADD: Yes, thank you.
See you next time.